[Música]
faz pouco tempo que eu passei por uma
experiência extrema
cheguei em casa de cá de manhã estava
sendo de uma aula
entrei em casa um cara abriu a porta do
meu carro e apontou um revólver na minha
cabeça estava encapuçado olhei para a
cara dele falei isso é sério uma reação
idiota porque quem é que a fazer a
brincadeira desse tipo de manhã às 10 da
manhã cafés e é sério tece levou até a
sala da minha casa
estávamos toda a minha família os
funcionários
todo mundo de cabeça pra baixo dominado
e os 89 caras todos encapuçados com
revólver fuzil
esse tipo de violência de invasão
uma hora dessas é aquela coisa né você
pára e é um cada fração de segundo é
inacreditavelmente lúcida
você olha assim quer dizer você não diz
nada nessa vai agir por alguma força
superior ao extinto mas o que sobra
dessa experiência é que a gente faz
escolhas
a cada fração de segundo
escolhas vitais escolhas algumas tão
radicais quanto essa né que pode
significar vida e morte e outras que
parecem e significante pequenas e
cotidianas diárias de rotina mas que
acumuladas mudam o curso das nossas
vidas
eu venho muito tempo além de fazer o que
eu faço
sabe é só tristeza escritora preparando
agora tô chegando a filmar
estão filmando a segunda temporada do
vida secreta dos casais têm desviou e
têm a rede felicidade que eu convivi
todo mundo pra entrar e fazer parte de
uma rede que acredita que a felicidade é
uma coisa que a gente tem que espalhar
que a gente tem que distribuir que
quanto mais a gente distribui a
felicidade mas ela se alastra e mais ela
volta pra nós eu tenho feito muitas
palestras falando sobre esse tema e
muitos lugares as pessoas argumentam
como falar de felicidade num mundo tão
cruel no mundo tão hostil no mundo tão
conturbado com o tamanho as diferenças
sociais com tanto ódio tanta violência
eu acho que é justamente porque o mundo
está assim que a gente tem que falar de
felicidade que a gente tem que espalhar
o melhor porque o melhor mesmo que
esteja escondido é a grande maioria
mesmo que seja a mais há o lado mais
aparente seja esse lado
pior esse lado ruim
então você pensa mas tudo tudo está
contaminado
não não é verdade está em nós em todos
nós a grande resistência ea felicidade é
a grande resistência o que é a
felicidade faz comigo numa hora dessas
eu tô ali tudo o que eu aprendi tudo que
eu estudo tudo que eu pesquiso tudo que
eu tento passar todo o time mesmo
pensamento positivo toda essa energia
essa vontade que os outros se melhor em
que eu possa melhorar para que o mundo
possa melhorar porque começa com a gente
e se alastra no nosso primeiro um
pequeno grupo social aí aumenta que nem
uma pedrinha que joga na água que vai
formando aquelas aqueles círculos até
que chega o nosso bairro
a idade do nosso país chega para o
planeta
mas numa hora dessas alguns caras e
apontando o revólver na cabeça será que
isso aí adianta alguma coisa será que o
cara lá tinha razão que a felicidade
adianta
acontece que a felicidade começa no
autoconhecimento
ela começa naquela viagem que a gente
faz pra dentro que é única jornada
possível pra você encarar o mundo porque
se você colocar a felicidade fora de
você
se você colocar a felicidade no que o
outro quer ou em alguma coisa que tem
que acontecer dali a pouco daqui a
alguns anos um dia quem sabe quando eu
consegui isso
quando aquilo chegar a mim é claro que
você vai estar sempre diz balançado
você vai ter sempre desequilíbrio você
vai estar sempre na maré do que os
outros proporcionam pra você e não na
tua própria força no teu próprio pilar
naquilo que você descobre um
autoconhecimento
naquele instante você fala assim
uma coisa porém extinto por intuição e e
o autoconhecimento de trás a compreensão
das suas inteligências a tua
inteligência acional que a tua lógica
aquela que a gente mais usa que é mais
conhecida como inteligência mas não é só
ela a tua inteligência emocional que
nesse momento ela é super importante
porque sem ela você pode perder o
controle se pode sair gritando igual a
louca pode ter reações em previstas e
provocar uma catástrofe porque é uma
coisa você pode ter certeza aqueles
caras encapuçados com fuzil revólver na
sua cabeça tem mais medo do que você
e olha que eu estava morrendo de medo
então o que acontece
a tua inteligência acional emoção
tal psíquica você não pode transformar
esse grande evento num trauma num numa
coisa que vai gerar um pânico uma
possibilidade de encarar o mundo com
medo de tudo então a gente tem que olhar
para aquilo e saber como funciona essas
três inteligências e por fim a
inteligência espiritual aquela que se
conecta com o estado superior com uma
força maior que a gente mesmo aquela que
a gente sabe que está com a gente mesmo
quando a gente acha que está sozinho
a nossa fé nossa a nossa conexão com o
mundo já está o tempo inteiro conectado
todo mundo aqui os seus celulares a
gente está muito muito as grandes
conexões as grandes tecnologias desse
momento dessa era tão interessante mas
ao mesmo tempo a conexão maior àquela
conexão que pra dentro de nós
a gente esquece de fazer essa conexão é
fundamental
é ela que vai destrinchar essa pessoa
que você é ela que vai descobrir quais
são suas emoções porque elas existem
porque que você tem dificuldade de falar
de seus sentimentos porque aquilo tem
emperrado porque aquilo dói e porque
nesse momento eu vou enfrentar ísso e de
que maneira eu vou olhar pra esses caras
que tremem com revólver com a mão no
gatilho
naquele momento eu trouxe não sei nem de
onde uma força uma serenidade
eu não sabia nem de onde eu estava
tirando a ser super honesto com vocês
mas foi até o ponto essa serenidade que
eu falava assim olha vocês têm que ficar
muito calmos ponto vão ficar calma vamos
pensar agora peguei a mão de um deles e
foi assim olha pra mim como tomo vamos
fazer um pensamento positivo junto para
tudo isso da penha é certo
[Aplausos]
eu sei que parece surreal né depois que
passa mas foi a única maneira que isso
modificar sereno por incrível que pareça
uma invasão seria num assalto sereno a
ponto dos caras botar o revólver no
bolso das costas pra gente
isso obviamente não tirou a dor é
invasão eles levaram tudo que eu tinha
mas também me fez pensar em outra coisa
levaram coisas materiais
não que eu sei o que eu faço alguma
colagem apologia do não-material acho
que a gente trabalha pelo material
material rege o mundo
a gente precisa sim de um monte de coisa
ea gente quer mais e agora é natal a
gente vai ter mais coisa enfim tudo isso
não só não é contra isso mas é pensar na
hora que sua tão perto de você no que
realmente custa caro e no que realmente
tem valor
são duas coisas muito diferentes o que
custa caro
é aquilo que o cara chegou assaltante
entra e leva leva embora
você não tem mais aquela coisa cara
barata boa bacana não valia muito mais
gostava uma bijuteria uma jóia de
família fosse o que fosse
também não tinha muita coisa mas enfim
isso é o que você pode comprar agora tem
aquela coisa que não tem preço mas tem
um valor inestimável
aquela coisa que ninguém tira de dentro
de você
aquela coisa que ladrão nenhum leva onde
quer que você esteja porque o que você
construiu dentro de você você construiu
ea sua e é esse o maior tesouro que você
carrega e é esse o tesouro
porque você tem que cuidar e é esse que
você tem que distribuir este tesouro
obedece uma matemática fabulosa
quanto mais você distribui quanto mais
você divide mais você tem inexplicável
mas verdade porque também é muito fácil
você é desenvolver uma vida z em cima do
time der e subir no morro meditar é
muito fácil a gente se abraçar querer
bem depois de uma meditação numa festa
numa congregação no momento de
felicidade de todo mundo junto
difícil é a gente manter esse espírito
manter essa força essa qualidade essa
serenidade no meio do caos no meio do
trânsito no meio da diversidade no meio
do desafio no meio do obstáculo na
periferia onde deus não está olhando
difícil é naqueles lugares onde a sombra
onde a escuridão você levá los
esse é é um desafio tremendo
esse é o momento que você põe em dúvida
e questiona tudo mas ao mesmo tempo é a
única coisa possível porque a sombra ea
escuridão elas existem mas elas aparecem
quando a gente acende a luz então cada
vez que alguma coisa ruim aparece a
gente é embotado de má notícia todos os
dias de uma forma até que intoxica gente
a gente tem que pensar isso é
interessante estão acendendo a luz
a gente está vendo aquilo que a gente
não conseguia ver e desenvolver dentro
de nós uma extraordinária solidariedade
uma extraordinária
a sensação de todo porque nós somos um
todo uma situação extrema texas é apenas
uma distorção como tantas distorções
existem por uma desigualdade social por
uma extrema miséria por um descaso por
uma negligência por uma série de
questões vitais e sociais que a gente
combate no nosso dia a dia mas por outro
lado a verdadeira maneira da gente
seguir em frente e conseguir sim de uma
forma positiva de pensar no nosso dia a
dia isso vai dar força pra gente levar
adiante a cada minuto e enfrentar um
momento desses de uma maneira serena e
sair ileso e quase que feliz você só
pode ter tentado desenvolver alguma
coisa profunda dentro de você e essa
coisa profunda vai comunicar vai
conectar com todos nós porque nós somos
um todo e nós eu acho que aí entra entra
uma irmandade e não só as mulheres têm
uma força muito grande nessa irmandade
mas os homens revelando essa porção
delicada que eles precisam revelar na
nossa sociedade porque a delicadeza
também está dentro deles
o sofrimento a dor a fraqueza também
está dentro deles ea gente precisa se
unir a gente precisa se unir a gente
precisa trazer essa forma amorosa de
trazer uma nova qualidade de vida
trazer uma irmandade trazer uma união e
sobretudo traver dentro do nosso coração
uma gratidão imensa porque é isso que
vai trazer essa conexão maior uma
gratidão enorme com tudo que nos
acontece
mesmo as coisas ruins uma gratidão
enorme
nós estamos aqui nós estamos em busca de
nós somos pessoas com poder
cada um de nós pode descobrir o seu
próprio poder
cada um de nós é um agente de
transformação
você consegue como eu consegui
transformar um momento horrível
no momento melhor no momento mais sereno
a gente consegue transformar o nosso dia
a dia a gente consegue transformar nossa
vida a gente consegue transformar a vida
dos outros a gente consegue isso é muito
mais produtivo muito mais feliz e desejo
a todos vocês a gratidão constantes no
coração e um caminho de muita luz
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]